josef von herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video gern fertig leute ich war
die letzten beiden abende feiern und
wird einfach nur mit meinem deutschen
geistlichen für euch und zwar machen wir
heute 16 uhr bis do finger und wie lange
musste noch studieren ich bin jetzt
gerade in witten semester von acht der
meinung ja brachte matters bei uns diese
an das leid in den meisten noch nie
dabei ich muss noch dieses semester
fertigmachen damals noch versucht
schreiben
im nächsten semester dann nur meine
bachelor studium schreibt meine große
haus zum abschluss die muss im nächsten
semester machen also insgesamt noch ein
knappes jahr sehr gut glaube ich hab gar
nicht nun wirklich lieblingsfilm ich hab
kein gebiet film und hat auch nicht
wirklich verarbeitet
bei solchen sachen mega schwer mich auf
eine sache festlegen weil ich werde
einfach viele farben geilheit die endeca
latitude vor dem entsprechend basic bei
mir auch im detail hochnehmen das keine
frage weil er die rückseite manchmal mit
apa red
möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen
ok montag ruhig mal informationen zu dem
neuen world project wurden kann leute es
gibt momentan noch kein sex word projekt
in richtung klamotten was ist aber sehr
wohl gibt sind opfer wahrscheinlich
kommen werden ihr wählt ihr hier schon
dass jetzt der einzige existierende
escape hauptwerke auf der ganzen welt
momentan ist einfach nur ein muster was
nur ich hab ich überlege momentan die
frau zu bringen weil ich koche gewitter
weil einfach echt geil finde ja dass
auch in der scheiße die mega unbestimmte
zeit in ihr handy klebt aber wir sind
tatsächlich nein als spielerei iphone
nur hierfür woher könnte es kommen wenn
etwas damit zu tun hat er sich erfüllt
er einfach selbst übertrieben auf deinen
setzte galileo mystery mittel ja gute
fall gibt eine sache die ich mit
absoluter leidenschaft und die fall
gehört das darf mir soweit ich bin
kleiner kritiker ja immer schon sagen
dass mit absoluter leidenschaft machen
wenn ich mir es gibt eigentlich gern
aber ich habe meine sachen gefunden und
war ich bin einfach rampensau leute ja
ich mag es einfach im mittelpunkt zu
stehen und sagen ganz offen auch kein
problem mit was ich will der spd nicht
vorträge hat ich hätte so gerne vorträge
vor dem publikum zu stehen und publikum
zu unterhalten seit über youtube oder
sei das letzte das ich in irgendeiner
schulen sowie letzten damit die schüler
rede
das finde ich einfach geil und ich das
mache ich noch mit seinem allermeisten
der größten leidenschaft
[Musik]
meine drei größten vorbilder auf youtube
momentan nummer 1 ins co pimco verhängt
einfach weil es geschafft hatte wurde er
sehr groß ist immer noch mehr oder
weniger natürlich begleitet wird wenn
möglich zu bezwingen ist wirklich so
aufgetragen öffentlichkeit normalerweise
auf ducati titel und so weiter bevor da
keine irgendwie was er nach models auf
seine exakt dass man bei ihm vor
deswegen
im kopf bewahren zweites vorbild
performance einfach ein verdammt
luftiger und witziger typ 1 projekte vor
mit jörg krämer alle hoffen euch kennen
wohl drittes vorbild ist jetzt nicht in
kassel vorbild würde das poster über
mein bett habe oder so mega fertig bin
oder so aber länger
ich würde so wie harry potter stanton
mega mega der hinterste mega girl
potter-filme abfahren blech harry potter
haut wäre okay folgendermaßen ich
wünsche euch littering anfangen und dann
zugriffen dorf wechseln
[Musik]
[Applaus]
gute gute gute frage weil es sagt grade
eben schon wieder so aus ich denke
gerade alles auch werke als auch was
passiert dann
hier testet kratzen meine mitbewohnerin
geht in die küche entsteht bei der mitte
wurde in der küche da drüben ja das ist
zwischen der küche und mir liegt einfach
ein meter und in der küche steht meine
mitbewohnerin die mit youtube gar nichts
am hut hat und koch da und ein solches
tier stehen und im youtube video
aufnehmen keine arme leute vielleicht
gibt anderen anders aber ich finde mega
orient und die freie ist verdammt geil
ich mir gerade eben gedacht habe es wird
zeit für eine eigene wohnung ist
probleme ich studiere nur noch weniger
als ein jahr hier das heißt ich wohne
noch maximal drei viertel jahr in dieser
wohnung keine möglichkeit den bock jetzt
noch mal umziehen weil du werde das
mandat in der küche indien
wenn die 2013 zum einen in die nacht an
praktikum gemacht und ich muss sagen für
die eingewöhnen man indien war relativ
hart
aber jetzt kennt nicht das ein bisschen
außen hab einfach mega profil dahin zu
gehen wo das letzte mal ordentlich wie
[Musik]
habt ihr ab juli plötzlich wurde mir
solche winter diesem punkt angekommen um
eine zuschauer mich fragen warum auch
meinen autogrammkarten meine
unterschrift drauf ist und nicht die von
apa red
[Musik]
egal
oder wie in stop gesagt hat habe ich
nicht gesehen
den ersten ball war nicht okay wer meine
lieblingsstrecke momentan eigentlich
drei rapper legte mich feuerwehr und
zwar als nummer 1 84 deutsche rapper
nummer zwei der troll die fertigen und
nummer drei
okay leute das war's von diesen
perspektiven ich will nicht für jemand
der auf der station macht deswegen hoffe
ich dass es für euch halt nicht recht
gehabt nicht alle aber trotz den vielen
dank zu schauen so weit nach oben